i think we're finally going to make the
last
talk on time and thanks for staying
for the very last talk for this morning
session
and we're very fortunate to have tim may
he is a phd student third phd student
here at uc berkeley and
we will continue discussing mi max
optimization in the convex concave
settings yeah so without further ado
yeah please take it away
okay so hello everyone i'm chin mei and
i'll be today presenting on
our recent work on zeroth order methods
for convex concave in max problems
and we present and a new application for
the main max domain
which is learning robustly from
strategically generated data
this is a joint work with these four
wonderful people
so let's get started so as we all know
machine learning algorithms have
occupied our lives a lot in these days
a typical machine learning algorithm
pipeline looks something like this
you have some data
which is sampled from some static
stationary
distribution you do some optimization
although you throw away some
optimization algorithm on top of it to
minimize certain loss function
and out comes a predictor or classified
in most of the settings which will
predict uh what should be a label or
what should be the value of the data
point which you are injecting at the
test time
so central dogma in machine learning is
as i said that observations are
independently drawn samples from a
static distribution
which is representative of the reality
and this kind of thinking has worked out
reasonably well in lot of settings which
we see today for example like object
detection recommender systems
and even in the fields like data driven
material discovery
uh
and and there are a lot of examples for
this so i will not bother you guys with
this
but there are certain challenges which
we must address timely in order to
develop next generation machine learning
algorithms
so i will present two such challenges
and will provide what work we have done
in resolving to
those two of those challenges in in some
way
so the first challenge is that of
distribution shift
and bias i guess a lot of speakers have
talked about this in this workshop
series
the distribution shift problem is
essentially that you cannot rely that
the data is coming from a fixed
stationary distribution
there can be
uh there can be certain adversarial
interceptions in your data set or simply
because some that some of the
environment in which you are using your
algorithm is non-stationary
so you need to
consider that effect while designing
these algorithms
so one such very interesting uh
unfortunate incident which happens when
we use machine learning algorithms if we
don't take into account such challenge
is that of a predictive policing
algorithm
so these days a lot of uh
cities use these predictive policing
algorithms primary
machine learning algorithm called pred
poll which decides how to allocate the
policing resources into some
neighborhoods in the city
in order to reduce crime or drug uses or
something like that
so this is a particular study which came
out in 2016 which talked about how how
to how were the drug arrests being
conducted in our neighboring city
oakland here
it turns out that
the data set which that machine learning
algorithm was using
was slightly biased because of some
historical reasons and towards some
particular neighborhood
in that city
and the data set was primarily
saying that the drug users were
concentrated in primarily two camps here
while the reality is that
there were some surveys which showed
that
in fact the drug users were like more or
less uniformly prevalent in almost all
of the city of oakland
what this kind of data set has led to uh
has led is that these predictive
policing algorithms will now mostly
predicting that police go into these
particular areas which are denoted by
red here only
and avoid the other areas which by the
way as per the ground truth has more or
less the same crime rate
so this kind of bias was which was
further propagated by use of this
algorithm
in fact it turns out that this sort of
uh output for this algorithm was
kind of uh unfair to people of color
uh because it led to a higher percentage
of arrest arrests for people of color as
opposed to people not of color
while in reality the
uh the drug uses was more done by the
people not of color
so one has to be careful while designing
machine learning algorithm which has
some such societal implications
and it turns out that this previous
article which came out in 2016
uh
we have not done much better because
there are there was one recent article
which came out in 2021 as well and which
kind of
emphasizes again on this issue of these
crime detection algorithms
there this other issue
comes out when you use these machine
learning algorithms in environments
which comprise of some strategic agents
so strategic agents will have certain
incentives which they want to maximize
and this that incentive might not align
with whatever was the main purpose for
which that machine original machine
learning algorithm was designed
so there is one more similar example
which kind of
shows this challenge which is about uber
search pricing
so recently there have been some
incidents where the drivers which use
uber app colluded
uh you know and then they turned their
availability off and which led to
which led the search pricing algorithms
to increase the prices for the customer
and in fact it led to higher prices for
the customer
so one has to now think about designing
these algorithms in a closed loop
fashion what do i mean by that so this
is the one of the typical machine
learning program which all of us are
aware of
but based on the challenges which i
presented before
one has to also consider this
the effect of adversarial perturbations
the data set
and also how does the outcome of your
machine learning algorithm in turn
affects the data which is being fed in
uh into that algorithm
so
one has to thus what we will be dealing
with today primary will be about robust
decision-dependent machine learning um
i'll refine these words more precisely
in the later slides
there are two primary questions here so
one question is about how to handle the
advert the robustness to some
adversarial perturbations data which a
lot of people have done which goes by
the name of robust optimization and
whatnot
and the other
other question is how to model
uh how does the outcome of the machine
learning
algorithm changes the data
so there are two questions primarily of
modeling and robustness
okay
so
today the main focus of this talk will
be about
uh how can we design a game theoretic
abstraction to the problem which i just
presented
and how can we tractively reformulate
that problem into a meaningful problem
which can be solved easily
and next uh taking inspiration from
whatever reformulation we get we we also
extend
uh the min max optimization uh the
designing of min max optimization
algorithms um
in a particular framework which i'll
present later on
okay
so let's just think about the problem
which i was talking about uh in a very
high level what does that problem look
like
so we all know in typical machine
learning optimization problem looks like
you have some data z which is sampled
from the probability distribution p
which is static stationary
and you minimize certain loss function
where
the loss function is parameterized by
data and the
uh and the parameter which learner wants
to learn
in art and which learner wants to learn
by minimizing this objective function
but while taking into account the issues
which i presented on on the previous
slide there are two concerns here one
concern is about dealing about the
uncertainty set which you have which
comes because of an adversarial
intersection in your data set
and also there has to be a component
which models how the
how the action or the outcome of the
machine learning algorithm changes the
data set
so it turns out that this problem now
becomes
in sub problem
uh if you observe if you assume that the
parameter theta lies in some finite
dimensional land but whatever you are
optimizing over here in the supe
variable
in the soup part is
kind of an infinite dimensional object
you are dealing with probability
distributions here
okay so let's just specialize this
setting a little bit to to consider a
particular application because the
previous problem was very general
so here we consider a specific
application of a
generalized dna model where the loss
function is takes this specific form
uh one example of this could be a
logistic loss which is used in a lot of
label prediction algorithms
uh
and let's consider this task of
predicting label y which is plus or
minus one given any feature x
uh a typical risk minimization we know
we'll solve this problem as i already
said
it turns out there has been some work
which also takes into account the
modeling question which i raised that
how does your
how do the outcome of your machine
learning model in fact
affects the data set and which was
studied in these works of strategic
classification or performative
prediction which talked about
what happens when your probability
distribution
uh from which you sample data set
depends on the
the the learning the the learner's
parameter theta
there has been another another domain of
machine learning research which talks
about
uh robust risk minimization
uh which typically studies these
problems of uh distributional robustness
when you assume uh we when you relax the
stationarity assumption of your uh
sampling distribution and you say that
that the same the distribution from
which you sample data set
lies in some uncertainty set which is
denoted by d here
and we now in this today's talk will
kind of combine these two lines of
thinking
and present a robust framework to tackle
this decision dependent aspect of
machine learning
so we'll be primarily focusing on this
sort of problem today where the
probability distribution comes from
uncertainty set which
depends on how does
the
which depends on the learning parameter
of the learner
okay
so let's just get uh like because since
again we have to put some structure to
get some meaningful results out of it
uh we'll deploy certain structure on how
the uncertainty set looks here
so there has been some work in the
distribution robust optimization uh
land where people have
uh kind of considered the reformulating
this infinite dimensional optimization
problem uh by suitably placing
assumptions of like that the answer they
said be moment bounded based uncertainty
set or it'd be a ball in a washer stein
metric or or there are a lot of these
reformulations
but in today's talk we'll mostly focus
on the setting where the uncertainty set
is a washer time ball of a specific
radius
so here to
to get
how does the
how does the
the outcome of your machine learning
algorithm affects the strategic behavior
which we want to observe so we assume a
particular structure on how does the
agents behave in this setting
so
let's say we have n agents whose ground
truth labels are denoted by x bar y bar
which are sampled from some distribution
d bar
which is their ground to distribution
which is the distribution prior to when
they have responded to the classifier
responded to the learners
responded to the machine learning
algorithm
we assume that agents will have certain
utility function and this utility
function is heavily studied in this
classification strategic classification
setting where we assume that the utility
function which agents have is they want
to be positively classified for certain
application domain for example
a bank granting loan people would want
to fund the bank to grant them low so
that's why this first term blue term
which denotes they want to go on the
positive side of the classifier and the
second term that this shift in their
features will not come for free they
have to pay certain cost in some sense
in order to change their feature and
that's why this
ping term here we denote the cost which
agents have
if you impose certain assumptions on
like convexity and homogeneity on this
cost structure
you can be sure that whatever
be the best response of these users be
will be a convex function in theta
and which has been shown uh in a paper
dong at all in 2017
uh
so what our goal here today is
we just want to state that this robust
decision dependent problem
can also be recast as a convex concave
min max optimization problem
in a
in a finite dimensional space
and to do this
we just use as i said that there has
been some work we showed the
if you assume this sort of utility
structure on agents
will guarantee the convexity part of it
and the duality part which ensures that
you convert this infinite dimensional
problem to a finite dimensional problem
comes from the watcherstein
distributionally robust optimization
which has been independently studied in
two works
okay so having said that i will not
spend too much time on how does the
actual optimization looks like because
uh what i want to emphasize more on this
talk is about the algorithm which we we
have proposed
which
is inspired from this this kind of
thinking of min max optimization
so what we observe that in these
strategic settings whatever algorithm we
use to solve this min max optimization
needs to fundamentally satisfy these two
requirement
one we do not will not have the exact
utility function which agents out there
are using in white
uh we will only get whatever response
agents do to
to the the to the learning algorithm
which we are using so that's why we our
algorithm should be based on some sort
of zeroth order optimization because we
cannot take gradients and stuff like
that
uh and also since here we are dealing
with agents or human beings at large we
cannot query them a lot of number of
times so you also want to minimize the
number of times we query such
individuals
so that will be the next focus of this
stuff
where i will talk about
a practical algorithm
which can which one of the use cases of
that algorithm is this application and
that can be used in in a lot of other
applications as well
uh which is a convex concave min max
optimization algorithm
okay so let's just briefly recap what a
min max optimization
uh what developments we had had in the
min max optimization land uh i agree a
lot of speakers before me have already
emphasized this point very very clearly
but
just for the heck of it i'll quickly go
over the slide which
uh which talks about the min max
optimization so
min max optimization is looks something
like this and the typical application
areas for this kind of optimization
algorithm is robust machine learning
algorithms where
people want to be robust against data
poisoning attacks or data evasion
attacks
um one of the
popular setting which has like
popularized min max optimization or game
theory in
um in in the in the community or the
machine learning community is that by
generative adversarial networks which
was proposed in 2014
um
there are some recent work which have
also cast the distributionally robust
optimization into a mid max framework
in a finite dimensional mid-max
framework which can be computed very
quickly using specified algorithms
also in any engineering design if we
want to talk about the worst case design
we always use some sort of a min max
optimization where we maximize
over
certain
actions taken by an adversary
and there are some quite recent
application which talks about the
fairness of machine learning algorithm
in this and apply such techniques such
algorithms to solve that
okay so
i i think i cannot do justice by talking
about all of the min max learning
algorithms in just one slide
i'll only denote those algorithms which
are which are related to the work which
i'll be presenting in next few slides uh
so as i said we'll be learning more
we'll be using mostly a zeroth order
algorithm or a gradient free algorithm
because of the applications from which
we have inspired this
uh
in the
so there has been a lot of progress in
the area of designing gradient-based
algorithms uh
and there are a lot of algorithms as
shown here which kind of have very quick
rates and can get you to the min max the
saddle point of the minimap solution
very very quickly
the progress in the gradient free
setting i would like to say is not that
much
it's still kind of an evolving feel
people are kind of analyzing certain
variants like strongly convex strongly
concave setting
or or some sort of other curvature
requirements in either x variable or y
variable
and there have been some work which
talks about the convex concave
optimization and just you the smoothness
of the problem and not just any any and
not any curvature on the objective
function
okay
so today i'll mostly talk
i'll use
these two main
algorithmic thinking paradigms of
optimistic gradient decent ascent and
convex i'll be working in convex concave
setting and with just a smooth objective
function
okay so
let's just quickly recap optimistic
gradient descent ascent algorithm
um which is
which was uh
i think
initially proposed in 1960s or 70s and
it has recently found out prominence in
in training of gans
uh after a paper by the scala case in
2018 or 2017
um so the problem is which we consider
here is that of
the same problem in max of a loss
function
um since we will be doing dealing with
certain data which is sampled from a
distribution we will typically have this
finite sum structure of the loss
function
uh and this loss function is assumed to
be convex concave and the sets are the
convex and compact sets
we all know what a gradient descent
ascent algorithm looks like
it
this algorithm
will take the current iterate and move
along the negative of the
gradient with respect to x direction in
the x variable and similarly move
similarly ascent along the gradient of
the loss function in the y direction
with particular step size let's say e2
it has been shown that sorry
it has been shown that the gradient
descent ascent if you work with
unconstrained setting i guess a lot of
speakers before me have talked about it
uh the interest of that algorithm
diverges
uh
even for a simple loss function like x
transpose y which is linear in x and
linear in y
um to tackle that there was uh an
algorithm proposed which is optimistic
gradient decent descent which kind of uh
directs the iterates in the right
direction by appropriately adding these
error terms
into
into the update of your equation
so this kind of figure denotes like how
the
k minus 1 and k8 is used to update for
the k plus multiplication
okay so this was a preliminary on
optimistic gradient descent ascent
um i'll also quickly recap what
uh a gradient freest setting looks like
so what in this work we'll do is we'll
just replace the gradients the actual
gradients with an estimate of estimator
of that gradient
and a typical
estimator which people use is this
randomized estimator which i'll present
on this slide
so consider a functional which is from a
space rd to r
the estimator of a gradient of this
function
by just using the function values of
this function is typically constructed
by
oops
by this kind of equation where
what if you want to compute a gradient
at a particular
point x
and a particular direction b what you
will do is just perturb
the you will perturb the point x
in an epsilon ball around that point
uh and you will sample a point v from
that sphere
uh uniformly randomly from that sphere
and construct this estimator which is
computed by just d over epsilon times
the loss function
times the direction which you are using
i think in this current form it may not
be very intuitive but if you want to
think about this estimator for the case
of d equal to 1
this estimator the expectation of this
estimator looks something like this
which is
in one dimension the sphere is nothing
but just a uniform distribution half on
plus n minus 1.
the expected value of this gradient
estimator then looks like
l of x plus epsilon and minus l of x
minus epsilon over 2 epsilon and this is
like
typically what
we use in a lot of engineering
applications when we don't have a
gradient
it's a two point estimator as a lot of
people call it
uh
it turns out there are
these it turns out that this gradient
estimator
may not have the property of
unbiasedness in the sense that the
expected value of this gradient may not
represent the actual gradient
of the loss function
but
one can say it's close enough
the expected value of this gradient
estimator
is in fact the gradient
of of the original loss function but
this loss function is now
now smoothed out in an epsilon ball
uh around every point so it is basically
doing this sort of
this sort of expectation uh where you
sample a direction uniformly from a ball
and you just smooth out that function in
a moment
it turns out that the bias of this
estimator varies directly with the
perturbation radius epsilon which we use
uh in order to construct this estimator
um
in in order to construct the zeroth
order estimator
uh
so but it turns out that the variance
will also grow if you kind of decrease
epsilon in order to improve iron so you
have to kind of trade off between
and choose one particular specific
epsilon in order to get the best
possible estimator for
for your setting and as it will turn out
in the theorems which i present later on
uh this kind of effect
or this kind of thinking will re-emerge
again
okay so as i said
uh the main algorithm which we will be
talking about today will be a practical
algorithm
so in a lot of these finite some
structure kind of loss functions
practitioners typically do not sample
data point uniformly randomly from all
the data points what they will do it
they will run the algorithm in epochs
and in every epoch they will fix a
permutation which is sampled uniformly
randomly
and then go over the data go over the
data set according to that permutation
and that is what is typically referred
as random reshuffling
um there has been a lot of a flurry of
research in the area of
uh
of of kind of giving rates for this
practical algorithm in the optimization
land
uh and these two are like
i believe one of one of the main papers
which kind of lead this
domain
but what we want to do is we want to
we want to use this kind of thinking for
the min max setting as well and try to
see
how does these algorithm perform in in
this setting
so just to give a very high level
overview of the algorithm which we are
using it's nothing fancy
we just use
the ogd update with a zeroth order
estimator and run a randomly shuffled
version of this algorithm
which is denoted here as i said so you
run this algorithm in epochs which is
denoted by little t
in every epoch you will sample
uniformly randomly from a permutation of
set of all numbers from one to n and
then go over data set one by one as per
that um
as per that permutation
and in the next epoch you will resample
and and do this process again and again
and and finally we will output an
average iterate
uh in the setting
so
to the best of our knowledge the
algorithm the algorithm presented here
is the first zeroth order randomly
shuffling algorithm for a min max
problem
okay
so let's look at how does the
convergence of this algorithm look like
so before talking about convergence one
has to think about what do you actually
mean by convergence in a min max
optimization
while we are solving any optimization
problem the convergence simply means you
decay your loss function
in the subsequent iterates but in min
max optimization it's not quite clear
because both the operation minimization
and minimax maximization are happening
simultaneously
so
it turns out
people use a variety of metric to show
convergence some some people use
stationarity conditions to show
stationarity conditions as a metric that
how far is your gradient being
not zero
but it turns out in the convex concave
setting you have a very good structural
metric which you can use in order to
evaluate the performance of any point or
in order to evaluate how
that point performs on the min max
operator
so we define this thing called delta
which we call will refer as cap
so given any point x and y
we compare the dis uh the loss function
or the objective function
at the point
x and y star and
take a difference with point x star and
y so now what are these point x star y
star so x star y star are the actual
solution of the min max problem
uh
okay and it turns out that this
this quant this quantity has good
property in the sense this is always
greater than equal to zero and it takes
zero value only at
uh
only at yours only at the saddle point
of the convex concave in max problem
uh just to see quickly why like this
kind of
operator is good enough if i write down
this operator again and add and subtract
these terms
l x star y star and l x star y star
it turns out that the first term which
is shown here we have here we have fixed
y so
and by the min max operation for any by
the x the x star kind of minimizes the
objective function if you fix y to y
star
so that's why
this this quantity will always be
positive and similarly if you fix x star
y star is the point which maximizes the
objective function
so this quantity will always be positive
okay so
after establishing that this delta is
kind of a good enough metric for
kind of looking at the min max problem
in the convex concave setting
uh i'll present the theorem which we
have for the optimistic gradient decent
ascent algorithm with zeroth order
gradient
and random visually quite a mouthful
it turns out that if you run that
algorithm for t epochs
and if you choose these step size which
step size here is the step size which
you use in the optimistic gradient
decent set algorithm and the
perturbation radius epsilon which is the
one which you use to compute the zeroth
order gradient estimator
in such fashion then this gap function
kind of decays at the rate of t to the
minus one fourth
um
right and the choice of these etas and
epsilons are typically governed
to kind of balance the bias variance
rate of which we obtained from the
zeroth order estimator
okay
uh one would say can we improve like
this looks may not be look very
promising rate to work with
uh can we improve this rate
so it turns out in this setting we were
using a very naive zeroth order
estimator which was just one point
estimator
that you
compute the estimator by just evaluating
the loss function at one point
um it turns out if you use a
a two point estimator which kind of
uh instead of doing l of x plus epsilon
v you also subtract l of x minus epsilon
v
you can improve this rate
uh to
d square over square root t uh i think i
forgot to put a d here
it's a d square also here
so it depends on the dimension of the
variables which you are working with
uh and you can improve that that the
convergence rate pi square to square
root t
it turns out we are primarily working
with this
this kind of rate or this is the first
thing which we keep which i am
presenting here because uh if you
remember the application which we
inspired the minmax optimization where
we had one decided data which talks
about that we want to minimize the
number of queries so if you are using
multipoint gradient estimator you are
naturally increasing more and more
queries
uh
for your algorithm but it turns out that
there is much more to this problem than
just that
and in fact
no one has ever analyzed this optimistic
gradient descendant ascent algorithm or
a min max algorithm with a random
reshuffling variant without any without
sorry it's just using a first order
information
it turns out you will drop this d square
term as well
because and you will get a rate of 1
over square root t
if you remember this d square was
primarily coming by the way we were
using
the we were constructing the zeroth
order estimator where you had d over
epsilon times the function value
okay so i'll quickly
go go over the
proof sketch
to
think about the proof there are
primarily three main results which we
use to
get the final rate
um i'll present these three results one
by one so remember the first sort of
bias which comes in
is introduced is by the random
reshuffling
as i presented uh on the previous slide
the randomly shuffling in every epoch
you fix the permutation over
over which you will go for that
particular epoch
and so in every time step when you use
the algorithm the iterates are not
uncorrelated as was the case with
the sgd update because there you sample
a new data point independently
uniformly randomly at every time step
so you naturally have some coral you
introduce some correlation due to
um
due to using random reshuffling so one
has to kind of deal with it
uh
so
this is the first result which talks
about the
uh the bias which is introduced due to
random resharpening
so
note that the bias
here will affect the gap function if you
recall the gap function was just the
difference operator which i just defined
which was l of x y star minus l of x
star y
um it turns out that this gap function
which we obtained gap function evaluated
at date rates of this algorithm which
you obtain
after reshuffling and the one which you
obtain without reshuffling you can bound
it by following the random reshuffling
literature in the optimization landscape
by just the difference between the
iterates which you obtained by two
specific
sequence of permutations which differ by
just one
entry point
in a sense if i if you give me two
particular
two particular uh
permutations of the data points one to n
which differ in one point in a specific
manner then you can show that this kind
of bias which is introduced due to the
random reshuffling can be bounded by the
difference in the iterate values
and just summed over all the 1 to n
i think this is not one of the main
contributions of this work this is how
typically a random reshuffling algorithm
is being analyzed in literature
is that you kind of construct two
iterates which are coupled with one
another and you kind of bound the versus
time distance between the two iterates
and you further bound the washington
distance by this two norm
uh which comes out naturally from the
definition i think i will not go too
much in detail for this lemma
uh because i think it will introduce if
i need to go specific going to
especially i'll need to introduce a
whole lot of notations which are not
relevant to the main
core of the proof here
the other core and the main
thing which we use here
is one of the main
proof techniques
the new proof techniques which we
introduce in the bin max literature is
this second lemma
which talks about this particular how to
bound this particular difference which
was first
introduced due to
the bias introduced due to random
reshuffling
so it turns out that the distance
between iterates which are generated by
two permutations of one to n
can be bounded by the number of points
where these two permutations differ
times the step size plus a factor which
comes in due to the zeroth order part of
this algorithm
so there are three main elements to
prove this lemma
the first thing is
what we need to do is
we want to
what we do in this proof is basically we
just get rid of all the zeroth order
stuff
by first bounding the difference between
the iterates of an ogd update which is
computed using the exact gradient
information
versus the zeroth order update which is
computed by the estimator which i
defined
and the blue term which i refer here is
precisely coming because of
the
the bias introduced due to the zeroth
order operator and this is again like
a usual zeroth order analysis is nothing
new
uh the main
key challenge here is to
to compute this difference
uh we next do is once we obtain a first
order ogda
update we exploit some of the recent
characterizations of optimistic grade
decent algorithm which shows that these
optimistic gradient descent estimate
algorithms can be thought of
as an approximation of the proximal
point algorithm which i think one of the
speakers talked before me
simply because the exact top single
point method you cannot use because
proximal point method is computationally
expensive you have to solve an implicit
equation in every time step
uh so it's good to
characterize the difference between ogda
and the proximal point method
and then using the fact that the
interests which are generated by the
proximal point method you can show
that the
the proximal point operator will be
non-expansive if the two permutations
agree
so for example if i use the same data
point to update my
algorithm
um it turns out that the proximal point
algorithm will be non-expansive so
that's why we just obtained this first
term which kind of captures
uh you will only
incur an additional
additional error
in the difference of iterates
uh whenever the permutations disagree
okay
so
using this sort of ideology here like to
compute the distance between iterates
now i will use
these two specific iterates which as i
said in the random reshuffling the bias
introduced random reshuffling
these two uh iterates s1 i and s2i will
only differ in one point and that's why
this term will essentially go off
um
or become just one not go off
and then you can you can like you have
essentially solved the issue of
characterizing
the difference between the bias
introduced due to randomly shifting
now next comes once you characterize how
the gap function will look like with and
without reshuffling
will then capture what would the gap
function look like if we had not used
the reshafted variant or we if we just
sample
a new iteration at every time step as as
per the stochastic gda kind of update
uh it turns out
again here to compute the gap without
reshuffling we first do the same step of
bounding the
difference between the ogd update
with the first order information and the
zeroth order information
and then as i said if you view again the
ogda as an approximation of the proximal
point opt proximal point update uh
following the kind of analysis
we have seen
for the ogd update in a recent paper in
2019
we get a standard telescoping sum
and we get
i think uh cos this has two questions
yep
russia
you want to ask online oh oh yeah sure
uh hi can you hear me
sorry i couldn't make it
there today because i was teaching until
uh recently so um i was confused could
you go back to your slide um
i was confused about uh which
distributions are you coupling so you
have you have n data points
so uh you're comparing a situation where
you take a random permutation of your
data points versus
uh you know
a batch that is with replacement
sampling so what exactly yeah could you
explain a little bit uh what are you
coupling here
uh yes so this gap without reshuffling
sorry
this time which is gap without
reshuffling this is the exact gap which
we evaluate at every point
okay and since our loss function is kind
of a finite sum structure which is one
over n of sum of lis
uh this gap function can be thought of
as
as the loss evaluated at a permutation
which is sampled at every time step
so if you sample
you you can imagine 1 over n of
summation of li as just expectation of
the l evaluated at a particular iterate
sigma which is
sampled uniformly randomly from
1 to n so that's what i mean here by
saying gap without reshuffling and gap
with regularly shuffling is just the
difference in the loss function
which we obtain by the actual iterates
of the algorithm which we obtained by
the following the random reshuffling
process
so s1 just to be clear s1 i is you know
in the
random shuffle the i
point
so s1i is in one of the epochs of your
algorithm you do it random resulting
yeah okay uh i s one i is
the i th point that you use in the in
your shuffle
s2i is just a completely random like
what what is this to uh it's like
can i think
right so uh i think i did not may not
have emphasized this point a lot here
thanks for asking uh so s1i
and s2i are both permutations from 1 to
n
okay
and
basically by i here i just denote
you just compute these
n
tuples of these permutations which are
s1i and s2i and s1i
is basically
a randomly
a uniformly randomly sampled
permutation for 1 to n
and s2i is you fix that
at a particular iterate that permutation
has a particular value
so
it is a conditional distribution in the
sense that s1i is a uniformly random
permutation from 1 to n and s2i is that
uniformly random permutation conditioned
on the fact that one particular iterate
uh or one particular uh
point in that permutation takes a
particular value from one to n
uh
okay
yeah so i i think yeah so this is not a
very good way to write these things
because without any notations but
um i think these are kind of analysis
which people obtain by computing these
two like uh these two iterates s1i and
s2i even in the random reshuffling with
optimization
and then
uh computing a lemma like this which
bounce the difference between the two
iterates
uh so we're just trying to
you know reflect that ideology here
okay thank you
yeah
yeah but i agree that it requires some
more notations to actually define this
object
thanks for your question
okay
so that's why i concluded the proof in
the sense that
on a high level the proof ideas looks
something like this
uh
we know this results which like which
one can write down that if your gap
function is calculated without any
reshuffling you can use this lemma
to compute
the cap function
uh as a telescoping sum plus some
quantities
um and these two quantities sorry i
missed one point so this quantity is in
the blue which is we obtained here
is because of the fact that we are using
a zeroth order estimator and that's
where as i said these etas and epsilon
has to be appropriately chosen
as we did in the theorem statement in
order to get the best possible rate in
this setting
okay so once so computing the gap with
without reshuffling is kind of uh shown
by lemma 3.
going from the gap which we get from the
reshuffle variant
we use lemma one and two
and in the final time step as i said
i'll just tune these parameters to
compute
the final rate so that's why we obtain
the
the final gap function which is with
reshuffled iterates
this is a very high level or proof
sketch
but yeah
okay
okay so now we just quickly return back
to where we started this whole journey
with
we are looking at this problem of robust
decision dependent
machine learning
which is described on this slide
we have conducted some experiment
semination primary experiment
uh
for a setting where
the the learner if you if you assume
that it's imperf in a realizable setting
where you
sample theta star
from a gaussian distribution zero
identity
uh and you sample all the features of
the data point from
the gaussian distribution and the
labeling is decided by this function
which just
captures on which side of theta star x i
lies
uh
and plus some some error term so this is
like the data set which we created to
analyze this algorithm
and the utility function which we obtain
uh which we assume on the agent's part
is takes the similar form as i showed in
in the previous part where i described
the strategic behavior
and here we use a specific form for the
numerical experiments that
the cost which agents get on changing
their features is a quadratic cost and
which
which kind of every player has a
different cost which is kind of
parameterized by
characterized by this variable zeta i
and as i said this actual utility
function is not available at the
algorithm algorithm designers
and while designing the algorithm so one
has to just query and work with it
um
okay and it turns out in this for the
simple utility function you can write
the best response this is just one
observation although we do not use the
exact value of best response
okay
so this is like one of where we
we
we evaluated these four
variants of min max optimization zeroth
order mean max optimization uh
so basically we analyze the stochastic
grade decent ascent and optimistic
gradient descent ascent uh both with and
without reshuffling
um and we observe that the with
reshuffling variants kind of perform
better than
uh without reshuffle variants
but there's also one more interesting
observation here that's a naive
stochastic gradient descent ascent
algorithm kind of
performs at par with the optimistic
gradient descent algorithm
and this is what we leave as a future
work right now we do not have an exact
analysis of why
how the stochastic gradient descent
ascent will behave with random
reshuffling
but the whole idea to take away from
this here is that with random
reshuffling also
as we as people observe in the
optimization landscape uh the same kind
of observation holds true in the min max
land as well
and it turns out that
since we designed this specific
specific problem formulation where we
are robust to any adversarial
perturbations to our data set
uh which is shown in this slide here
where
what we
observed that as you vary more and more
perturbations in your data set uh the
performance of a naive
uh
knife
just decision dependent machine learning
algorithm following the strategic
classification
literature we observe that the
performance of that classifier decays
very quickly as opposed with the
perturbations but the performance of
this robust classifier kind of stays
it kind of decays very gradually
so this is one what we would expect if
we have designed a robust classifier
okay so i'll escape these two further
experiments in the interest of time we
can discuss this offline
and what i'll want to go over right now
is some of the open problems which are
there in this domain
so i'll describe the open problems in
mainly three three categories one is the
algorithmic open problems other is a
modeling open problem
and then i'll go over a more high level
picture of how we should be thinking
about
uh designing this algorithm which will
be interacting with all of us in our
society at large
uh in the coming
days or it has already start
okay so in terms of algorithm
convergence
uh as to the best of my knowledge
the convergence of zeroth order method
uh for min max optimization for a
non-convex non-concave objective is a
largely open problem uh people have
analyzed variants for example in this
work we analyze convex concave variant
people have analyzed non-convex concave
variant or non-convex strongly concave
variant something like that
so yeah thinking about this and what
should be the measure which we use
uh is kind of
an open problem here the other thing is
that i stated the stochastic gradient
descent ascent which is like a little
bit simpler than an optimistic gradient
descent ascent algorithm
uh
with reshuffling is also still an open
problem
uh furthermore uh there is a lot whole
lot of work which one can do
to
design min max optimization with random
reshuffling and talking about variance
reductions on top of that
uh
so this is like we have barely scratched
a surface in this direction
in terms of modeling
as i said the model which i presented in
the first part of this talk
the agents were considered a myopic
agents which just
what they will respond directly to
whatever
uh class machine learning algorithm the
uh the the learner has provided to them
but it is not the setting in a lot of
scenarios people rethink their choices
and they kind of re-evaluate their
decisions and maybe they get better and
change their features for for
improvement
so
one has to think about uh you know the
strategic decision making with recourse
where people kind of the base
distribution of people also shifts based
on how they interacted with the
mechanism in the last time step
which is kind of largely missing from
the literature
um on a more like low hanging fruit in
this direction is
in this work we kind of assume the
vorstein ball
as a uncertainty set
in defining the robust
decision-dependent problem
it is i think a broadly open problem in
a distributionally robust optimization
as well is to come up with a tractable
reformulations with different
uncertainties uncertainty set which are
shown here there are like there are some
operation research people who are
actively working on this but all of
their results have just given us a
non-convex reformulation of the problem
and this is one of the setting which i
presented here that with versus
steinmetric we can come up with a convex
concave reformulation which is tractable
um
but yeah in terms of other uncertainty
set is kind of a largely open problem
thinking more abstractly one can talk
about settings where we capture the
behavioral models where these algorithms
will
and are interacting with human beings uh
how to work around with those kind of
very open open questions uh
okay so this is where i will conclude
that
um at this point
uh in the machine learning glance where
a lot of machine learning algorithms
have are prevalent in the modern society
uh
kind of lack a lot of aspects which one
has to be actively thinking about
uh be it fairness be it robustness
uh be it capturing the dynamical
interactions be it incentivizing the
agents for something
some common good and stuff like that and
i think some of the questions we will be
discussing in come upcoming workshop on
learning in the presence of strategic
behavior
and with this i'd like to thank
everybody for listening and any
questions and comments
thanks for the very nice stuff let me
see if there are any questions
i
[Music]
thank you for am
nice talk i would like to ask about the
an open question that you asked at the
end and i will try a little bit to
connect it
about the algorithmic perspective of
zero order min max optimization
so
uh
i am wondering um i will try to connect
the
this presentation with the presentation
of isnoy at the start of
this today's session
his notion of equilibrium uh
actually the only point that
you cannot take for example adversarial
grid equilibrium
is the
as far as the max player he used a monte
carlo method that is zero order for the
finite differences of the gray of the
stochastic gradient
the only question is if we have a
zero order method
to
converge to a local minimum
and i think we have that so in one sense
i think that we have zero order methods
that can converge to mean max solutions
[Music]
but
actually yeah my question is what is the
mean mark solution that you are seeking
uh
but i didn't get the last but um just we
want to solve the saddle point problem
of min max of l of x of y
um but
a part
regarding your comment about the zeroth
order algorithm for non-convex
non-concave setting
um i think i have not seen any paper
which has like most of the recent paper
which i was looking at where i as i said
either is imposing some sort of a
curvature requirement
on either the minimizing variable or the
maximizing variable be it strong
convexity or convexity concavity
something like that
let me ask the following can we have
assumptions about
the ellipsis-ness of the haitian of the
uh
of the objective function yes or no
if you give me anything that i can
create algorithm that can converge at
least to the
adversarial equilibrium of is knowing
maybe we can discuss it offline i don't
know
yeah i think we should discuss it
offline
yeah that would be good because we are
running a bit late and thanks a lot like
nissan speaker one more time for the
nice talk and uh we'll come we come in